Which fan -favorite star can be spotted
in the background of the final episode of
The Walking Dead? And how did they score thelow-key cameo? Keep watching for the details.
After 11 seasons and over 170 episodes, theiconic zombie drama based on the Image Comics
series has reached the finish line. The
Walking Dead capped things off with a very
eventful finale that even brought back severalfan favorites, including Rick Grimes and Michonne.
There was even a small cameo from ChandlerRiggs that many viewers might have missed.
Riggs played the son of Rick Grimes, Carl Grimes,for more than 100 episodes of the AMC series,
and during that time the character
had it pretty rough. Losing one's
childhood to a post-apocalyptic
undead nightmare is one thing,
but losing a mother and then an eye only
adds to the punishment the poor kid endured.
Despite surviving all of that, he was not able
to survive long enough to make it to the show's
final entry. Out of all the character endings on
The Walking Dead, Carl Grimes' death was arguably
one of the most outrageous moments on the show,and it didn't necessarily go over great with fans.
The character's final appearance was in Season 8,Episode 9, and he has not been on the show since.
"You okay?"
"I don't want you to be sad after this."
But the talented people in charge of the showtook advantage of an unexpected opportunity to
make sure the actor who played the legacy
character entered the frame one last time.
While Carl Grimes is long gone, Chandler Riggsmanaged to make it into the final episode of The
Walking Dead. Toward the end of Season 11,Episode 24, there is a scene at the Hilltop
community where Daryl Dixon and Carol Peletier aretalking to Maggie Rhee about what happens next.
In the background of that ordeal, there areseveral people working and doing farming
activities, including an individual standing wayin the back who looks suspiciously like a two-eyed
Carl Grimes. That's because it was Chandler Riggsplaying a hilltop farmer in the background of the
series finale. While you might think this
move was a carefully calculated endeavor,
that is simply not the case. It turns out it wasall by chance. The actor was visiting the set,
and when they needed extras, he was chosen bythe director Greg Nicotero, and Riggs did not
hesitate at the opportunity to get back into
The Walking Dead. He told Entertainment Weekly,
"Aunt Maggie!"
"Hey!"
Nicotero also revealed to Entertainment
Weekly that Riggs didn't visit with the
makeup or wardrobe departments and that he wentto work in the clothes he was already in, saying,
Norman Reedus was thrilled to
have his young co-star on set
and mentioned that he tried to let
the viewers in on the secret, saying,
"It's not like we're never
going to see each other again."
Maggie herself, Lauren Cohan, was also excited
to have Riggs back, telling Entertainment Weekly,
While it was brief and somewhat out of sight,
having Carl Grimes in the mix is a
fun little easter egg that fans will
appreciate. But it does feel safe to assume
that Riggs' series finale cameo could easily
make the list of Walking Dead cameos fans
probably missed the first time around.